how's it going red it's getting really
exciting let's go it so let's go with it
there we go all right my name is Perry
back
it's Marty 26 degrees the lost park
who the [ __ ] names very carnival the
last Park everything that I've been
through since the second I entered that
diner all of it was leading me to this
moment oh it's it's finishing I don't
want this game to fit no fighting
running and hiding all the time I was
moving anyway what the Rajan thing left
that cracking flowers Tiffani's life I
few crow and now now the homeless but I
did not to fight my destiny anymore
we're gonna [ __ ] my destiny not come on
why is she Tiffany yeah she's at the top
of the roller coaster I don't see it
find a way up there where I really oh
hello money joke friend can wait I need
my bonus point
hello carnival alright but seriously oh
there's a roller cutter okay
rub rub rub rub rub rub rubber but Rome
like oh Aaron s should be here so much
[ __ ] eggs okay she's fine
Jace's Christ we stopped screaming I can
actually try to help you when then I
don't even know what third I don't even
know one there we go
alright let's go in here um let's start
to roller coaster
cuz why not and see why I why I
shouldn't
whoops haha no way
No shut up shut up J says saved a great
girl [ __ ] that I'm on a roller coaster
let's go
but sick but safety first I love this
plans what the [ __ ] is going on
no no it's alright I was enjoying that
now what do you want tell me have you
not seen my lair oh yeah II haven't seen
my new skills all right let's keep the
balance
get ready oh you bet it's switched use
left and right arrow keys my god oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] ah ah
faster Lucas can you walk a little
faster please one step left to step
right I will let it dance on nipples all
night
go faster Lucas go faster Lucas go
faster Lucas go pass a loop go a little
faster please because I don't know ah ah
ah and that's how my story ends
officially they called it suicide how's
it a suicide
she's literally witnessing it to Galvis
you not a suicide oh well stop thinking
pity stop thinking look pop or the plop
aah plop aah plop aah plop aah plop aah
plop plop plop aah plop aah plop ah ah
1980 May okay this is really actually
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know what I just
said but I said it and I don't regret it
because you want just nipples face
tonight nap on face tonight bras nipples
face tonight
Danny talks genitals she doing are you
doing hello
right I want to look at it what's she
doing are you dying girl buddy
I'm right here you know all right let me
save you Jesus I have to do everything
here all right there we go
are you happy let's make love right here
right now a roller coaster
oh no it wasn't a roller car thing
Oh Otherworld is gonna kick 95 that is a
lot of minuses okay I got to pass the
Oracle hmm no Lucas first look it's over
now there's nothing to do but wait I
didn't belong perfect
all has gone according to plan why I
sent another signal what cerebral spinal
activity I think he's dreaming am I at
the hospital huh this is definitely in
the past huh I sleep with my clothes on
that seems simple I sleep with my shoes
on
yep I don't think there's anything
unusual with that at all
all right so let's go kill our brother
tell em what got Marcus it's time it's
time to make love hurry up we don't have
much time
[ __ ] hey you wanna go Lucas I [ __ ]
hate is why he's acting yeah it is not
fat one driver to go in there ready for
anything Marcus right maybe there'll be
an alien spaceship inside or the tomb of
an ancient king with all of his treasure
or Julian frozen dinosaur
yeah I've been cool it's a secret weapon
to take over the world
come on matauri the hair's gonna be
well-guarded we better get going if you
don't want mom and dad to catch us
sorry I said a couple sentences if
anything why do they sleep there anyway
we literally know nothing about their
parents they died in a car accident
they're gonna [ __ ] make set over all
shoot I'm sorry what the hell are you
doing out here at this hour we have our
[ __ ] home immediately a way we're
looking fired milk nothing at shed crazy
Lucas we're lucky that he let us go but
if he catches us again they're gonna be
our butts big you do what you want
Marcus I'm going back to do what you
want Marcus I'm going back I like but
reaching I actually enjoy it a lot come
out here you little [ __ ] and let's get
our butt beaten Oh No
I think really daggers right in front of
you yeah now is the time for spot ah
whoa don't move or I'll shoot
don't [ __ ] little boy shoot sir we're
just kids
we're the K boys what the hell are you
doing out here at this hour
get back to your home immediately we're
not doing better than expected I have no
idea how all right there's a guard over
here
okay what if we go now I can't [ __ ]
see because you're being a little [ __ ]
okay we try is a god right there
no did I tell you to [ __ ] move
okay we're here what do we do now
I never know what we need to go we
started here we're supposed to walk all
the way over there I don't know that
seems like a [ __ ] hassle to me let's
go back
looks like we got quick what time I what
the [ __ ] I wasn't even there
not the [ __ ] oh you're not hiding what
do you doing buddy you know had Mariana
ever stop dancing in front of the soul
yard how does he not see that you have
amazing chest elf skills holy [ __ ] I'm
impressed
my god man don't stop the dancing
walking on a polar bond my god that was
amazing I love you brother I love you
like oh hey oh Sh
neh stop burping I'm cereal and then I
can't walk here and the best of all the
wall what do I do
[ __ ] you a vegetable walls [ __ ]
you oh this one looks scary better watch
out for that one Ron Ron Ron like a
[ __ ] don't touch me don't touch me
don't touch me I came so far to look at
all Andy and I got bat [ __ ] what's with
the camera angle how am I supposed to
see well man no no now today Jennifer
Lopez Jennifer Lopez I love Jennifer
Lopez I love jennifer lopez i love
jennifer lopez i love jennifer lopez i
love again ron jennifer lopez boo jolly
fellow myselves close alright so we have
uh one in the [ __ ] here why is there an
X there was that me or the X me I mean I
have to go there or I'm obviously not
taking the route they want me to take
you can't go any further that soldiers
blocking the way he's not rinse ego
ground look back and find a way to avoid
him how about you do it you're fat
[ __ ] and whenever I said sneak around
the bag and wishing [ __ ] him
alright so now we can change to that
little [ __ ] I guess I was the idea all
along
I know I should stake around the back
what why what is this
why why did he do that how does it make
any [ __ ] sense
oh well ah dad if I not in fact damned
if I don't come closer
all right
and that God is just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
how did we get past him though let's try
over here
I got the feeling it's over here though
so let's go let's let's trust our trust
instinct [ __ ] I hate this part but I'm
doing so well I would I failed a couple
first [ __ ] Fox but after that for
Marcus before going on
oh that Marcus you didn't follow me ran
away from Marcus because otherwise this
would be too easy for them and not
frustrating at all we need to make
frustrating the gameplay not frustrating
enough there we go no Jennifer Lopez
hello Jennifer there we go what's up you
guys can do your brotherly thing I am
not sure exactly what it in malls but
from now on I will not be a part of it
alright so now that real [ __ ] is
following the other [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
tastic as I like to talk
what's with the camera angle okay we got
that little bit you're what the only way
to get to the hangar without being seen
is to climb up a telephone pole and hang
off of the cable impossible that pole is
right under the guards no I know but
there's no other way these guys I'm
gonna try to get him to look the other
way
meanwhile you run and climb up the pole
I'll try to set it up so you have enough
told me okay but how are you gonna get
in meet you back at the house you tell
me everything when you get back at least
that way we'll know for sure whether
there's a flying saucer in that hangar
flying saucer I love flying saucers
alright so he will distract the guard
how I am NOT sergeant perhaps going over
here no wait I need to go where the XS
so let's do that these guys are [ __ ]
ambitious you gotta give that to them ok
ok thank you
Thank You game Thank You game Purdue
making me do this by the way I don't
know if I told you before there we go do
your little thing kick them out nice
it's all up to you sounds beautiful Wow
he's my new favorite character hey why
do you think you're doing there I'm
kicking battles I'm looking through my
cat sir he ran out of the house I said
we got a car but they my Highway before
I could grab one of the cane boys right
head on home son
you should be out prowling around alone
at this hour what about my cat sir well
yeah what about tomorrow right now you
go on back home I'm a seal mother [ __ ]
am i seein a mice here oh it I'll shut
up I coulda polish this game play a
little bit it looks a little awkward if
you ask me but hey just my opinion who
gives this [ __ ] all right I think we'll
time this one actually pretty good all
right
oh [ __ ] go faster Lucas nailed it nailed
that [ __ ]
oh alright let's go this game I have to
say it's interesting and it's like
entertaining but it's it's so flawed
it's so [ __ ] flown and I can't help
laughing at it okay so now we just got
[ __ ] never mind a lot of the entrance is
the part that is least guarded yeah we
should put all their all the security
cameras it off a little bit away from it
you know why should we put it at the
entrance when we can put a little bit
farther away yeah that's a good overall
shock what the hell are you doing out
here this up I don't know I hope there's
a save right yes I wish I did this all
alone so that was a lot of [ __ ] work
for a bunch of curious the boys I hope
there's something [ __ ] good in here
better be
Wow no password no anything you just
roll down the lever huh okay now that
makes sense
I press I have to had this episode here
come on show us quickly what it is
it's a Mayan artifact probably isn't it
alright I guess I don't show us those
little [ __ ] anyway like very few enjoy
subscribe comment read today and I'll
see you next time
heavy red ah does oh hi there you are
you naughty that Greenland oh I got it
slow and [ __ ]
apply no hide and boil in a wedge I was
uptight oh I'm a mother
let's go joys yeah oh my god what if I'm